In order to condense this expression
the first thing I'm going to do is condense within
each term.
To do that I need to use the power property
so that we can get rid of these coefficients.
Doing that gives us-
log of x cubed plus log of y squared minus log of z to the one half.
However I also know that z to the one half
is just the square root of z.
So I think I prefer to write it that way.
Now we've gotten rid of our coefficients
we're finally allowed to use our product and
quotient properties.
>From the product property we know that log of x cubed plus log of y squared
is equal to log of x cubed y squared.
Since we're subtracting log of the square root of z
from that,
I can use the quotient property as well.
The numerator of our fraction is going to be
the input of the first log,
and the denominator is going to be the input of
the log we're subtracting.
So that means that in the end we've condensed our original expression-
3 log of x plus 2 log of y minus one half log of z
to be just this little compact thing right here-
log of x cubed y squared over the square root of z.
Awesome!